وصل اذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن الى تل ابيب لاجراء محادثات مع
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين بشان حرب غزه وكان
بلينكن قد قال انه وجد قاده المنطقه في
الدول التي زارها عازمين على منع اتساع
نطاق الصراع بين اسرائيل وحركه حماس في
غزه بلينكن اضاف في تصريحات قبيل مغادرته
السعوديه ان جميع من تحدث اليهم يدركون
حجم التحديات ولا احد يعتقد ان شيئا سيحدث
بين عشيه
[موسيقى]
وضحاها في كل مكان ذهبت اليه وجدت قاده
مصممين على منع الصراع الذي نواجهه الان
من الانتشار ويبذلون كل ما في وسعهم
لتفادي التصعيد ومنع توسع رقعه النزاع
تحدثنا ايضا عن مستقبل هذه المنطقه واعتقد
ان هناك اتفاقا واسعا على بعض الاهداف
الاساسيه اولا ان يعيش الاسرائيليون في
سلام وامن متحررين من الخوف من اي هجمات
ارهابيه او عدوان من اي من جيرانهم ثانيا
ضروره توحيد الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه في
ظل حكومه فلسطينيه ثالثا يجب ان يكون
مستقبل المنطقه مستقبل تكامل لا انقسام
وصراع ورابعا لكي يحدث ذلك علينا ان نرى
قيام دوله فلسطينيه لا احد تحدثت معه
يعتقد ان هذا سيكون سهلا يدرك الجميع
العقبات ولا يعتقد احد
ان اي شيء سيحدث بين عشيه
وضحاها